linear this was such a tense balanced
match between you two that it started
off with the classical match it felt
like you had some sort of a pool but he
defended just incredibly well and it
ended up with this game sum it up for us
yeah it was very uh even much of course
uh in the classical game I got a nice
position but I think he knew quite well
the the end game that it's just a draw I
mean it looks of course very scary for
black but if you know it's raw then did
you know so scary I remember checking it
like but long time ago because I
remember there were a couple of games of
1u against Lego I think and uh and maybe
another game of jakobenko against Alex
save probably uh and I was checking it
back then and I remember it was a draw
with very precise play but then it all
depends depends on some Pawn placement
and I thought it's like a nightmare for
for black in practice but I think he
knew quite well
uh and then yeah I didn't have much to
do and then yeah the the tie breaks of
course in the first game I didn't get
much with white and then it all came I
mean the the second game I was I think I
got a decent position from the opening
did you feel like he was taking
unnecessary risks or I thought no I mean
I I thought it's just a normal position
uh I was expecting something like Rook
81 in this position and then play for
Bishop D4 try to trade his Bishops I
thought black has a has a good position
anyway but uh but it's probably balanced
that's what I thought during the game
and after Knight A4 did you start yeah I
mean reading about potentially I thought
finishing them I thought I have to play
Queen B5 but I didn't know that it was
so great but once I started thinking I
realized that it's quite unpleasant for
for white now because I have the Bishops
and then the Rook is coming to E2 and
and yeah White's position is just really
unpleasant at this point and I think
after that I had to find a couple of
size move like this Rook C2 because yeah
the point was that if I play Rook a E8
which is a natural move the Knight C3
holds for white and I cannot take on B2
now take and then right yeah because the
thing is after Knight C3 I always have
Queen takes B2 in general that's why for
example instead of rookie E1 Knight C3
uh it's not possible this time because
now right yeah that's the point but
that's why Rook C2 is very strong just
keeping the the Knight on A4 out of out
of the game and now always Knight C3
I'll take on B2 with the queen yeah and
yeah and then I had to find this uh okay
Rook ac8 I think was also precise with
the Rook F2 ideas and then it was just a
I had to calculate with a little time
but uh thankfully I had the Berlin event
just to work a little bit the
calculation with with a few seconds so I
was I was able to do it quite quite well
a big match is uh coming against Hikaru
Nakamura player that feels like he's in
great shape how are you going to
approach that one yeah so he he seems to
be in great shape but I'm just quite
happy that I qualify against such a
strong opponent like the one so I'll uh
uh I just try to enjoy victory for a
little while for a couple of hours yes
and then I'll see how I will approach
the next one linear we'll see you
tomorrow thank you congratulations our
congratulations indeed and good luck uh
with your match against Hikaru